the first thing i want to say is i'm
interested in aristotle on anger
primarily because
it's something that he talks about in a
lot of texts that's why i gave you that
handout an aristotelian text
looking at dimensions of anger if you
look at that you notice that he talks
about it not just in the nick of mccann
and you damien ethics where you'd expect
to see something on it
he also talks about it in the rhetoric
but also it comes up in the politics the
dionyma
and a number of other texts and i've
distinguished six different
sort of aspects or dimensions
of aristotle's discussions of this
because he doesn't examine it from just
one single perspective
there's a lot of different overlapping
perspectives
so
anger itself
understood is organ in greek or the most
in greek there's there's some questions
about you know when can you translate
one as
as anger and the other is something else
it comes up an awful lot and it occupies
an important place in aristotle's luck
but he never wrote a treatise on anchor
as a matter of fact he doesn't have
anything like you know
the book on across fiat and a few other
things in the nick of mccain ethics or
on choice or things like that instead
what you have to do is bring together a
lot of different
threads and you try to think these
things out in a way that's kind of
faithful to aristotle but isn't
explicitly there in aristotle
so
what i'm going to do here today
is i'm exploring something that has to
do with one of the chapters that i'm
writing
and it comes out of um nickel mccain
ethics book seven where aristotle very
explicitly talks about anger
um generally in terms of the most not
organ
and there's this phenomenon that we call
lacrossia
so the things that he says there seem to
be illuminating at first blush but then
turn out not to be quite as illuminating
and to raise a lot of other puzzles for
us
and i think that a lot of these puzzles
come up in part because
it's not always clear exactly what
aristotle means by across ya it's not
always clear exactly what role anger
plays or what's going on what what angle
he's taking on it so i wanted to try to
clarify this a bit so in order to do
that
one of the things that i'll have to do
is talk a bit very briefly
about
aristotle and anger i'm not going to go
into great depth on that
but you have these these handouts that
give you a lot more information
and then we have to look at across the
in general and then we'll try to bring
them together
and we'll do that in in two main ways
one is by looking at what aristotle
himself actually says
and then we'll see what could be said
from an aristotelian perspective that
aristotle didn't say but i think he
ought to have said or you know at least
could have
had good grounds to say
um so what i'm doing in this and what
i'm also doing in the larger book
project
is something that
there's a guy david wiggins who's done a
lot of scholarship on aristotle and
practical rationality and
emotions and he talked about the need to
give an account that he said i would
almost venture to call a more
aristotelian account than aristotle's
i think that in a lot of cases with
aristotle we have to do this especially
when it comes to topics like acrostia or
anger
so a few general remarks before we start
on across the anger itself in aristotle
across here is a term that we translate
in older translations as incontinence
not a particularly helpful way to talk
about it today because of all the
associations that we have with it's too
narrow just like when we think about
vice quite often people think about
smoking and drinking right but they
don't think about vices more broadly
you can also translate it as weakness of
will but that's kind of problematic as
well because aristotle doesn't have a
conception of the will
the way that say augustine does
you can try to shoehorn pro-erasus which
is translated as moral choice or
deliberate choice or a few other things
depending on who you're looking at
as the will
and some people try to do that with
epictetus as well because he uses that
term
but i don't think that's a very good fit
i think these are somewhat different
things
so
weakness of will isn't really going to
do it so how about
lack of self-control
that seems to be the translation that's
easiest to get our heads around that
seems to be the least confusing
and that's a phenomenon that we we do
experience
you know we have cases
in uh whether we're observing other
people or ourselves where we know what
the right thing to do is or we know that
we ought not do a wrong thing and we
know that it's wrong but we find
ourselves doing it
and the question that
across is an answer to is well how's
that possible
given our understanding of rationality
or given our understanding of you know
the way the emotions and desire
interface with rationality how how is
that actually possible
i think that aristotle's
attempt to try to grapple with this is a
major contribution to moral theory
and we're talking about this on the way
in you know there's there's not a lot of
people writing articles saying well
there's no such thing as across ya and
although one could
and why is that well
this guy richard robinson has a great
quote quip about that he says evidently
aristotle did not near write nearly a
whole book on a crosstalk to deny that
it ever occurs he thought there was
something there
now whether he got it right in all of
its respects that's a that's a different
matter
aristotle himself would be
very welcoming to the idea that maybe he
didn't have it all completely correct
and that
his account needed to be improved
his treatment of across ya if we're
looking at the most developed ones of it
so that's in the
nick of mccain ethics primarily but also
the udemian ethics it's a dialectical
one
so
that means that he's bringing together a
lot of different people's ideas views
opinions about this and then trying to
sift them and see
what truth there is in them and then
trying to kind of cobble together
an account
that would
bring together all the things that are
actually correct and
even to some degree explain why some
people have got it wrong
did he succeed in that not not
completely we can probably like i said
improve on that
scholarship on aristotle on these issues
on anger to some extent there's not as
much research on that but on across you
is actually all over the map
people have made a lot of different
things of this they're not all
in complete agreement so it's kind of
open territory for people to work with
um
i'm going to skip through a little bit
of this what can we say about anger then
anger is important for aristotle too
it's an emotion in terms of which we can
be a craddock
we can have weakness of will or failure
to do the right thing
without necessarily being morally
vicious
and aristotle thinks that it's different
from across ya by itself but across you
per se parasia
simply as he puts it so how is it
different that's part of what we're
going to to explore
now across the itself has to do with
among other things a conflict that's
internal to the person
something is going on in them they're
not fully integrated
the way that the virtuous person would
they're not even fully integrated if we
want to call it that in the same way
that a vicious person is
although you know we can't speak of that
in quite the same terms as a virtuous
person so there's a conflict going on
what is the conflict between
well when it's in terms of anger
aristotle actually says anger is itself
a distinctive form of affectivity or
desire
he calls it thumbos
he also uses the more specific term
organ for the the passion itself of
anger but he switches back and forth
sometimes actually in the same passage
especially in the rhetoric
um
we want to figure out how
anger itself can make a person
and how that would be different from
other types of across you
so
first thing that we're going to look at
then is
aristotle's um
aristotle's views on anger
so anger itself is what it's an emotion
it's a drive it's something that we we
experience we have a
great amount of observations of our own
anger other people's anger we know what
it feels like we know what it's like to
be driven by it but we don't always
conceptualize it uh quite as well and
aristotle spends more time on anger in
analyzing the emotions than any other
emotion if you read
the rhetoric book two where he starts
you know really discussing the emotions
he does that
in great depth compared to some of the
the other emotions
anger seems to have
a unique status
it's a distinctive form of desire
different from the other desires
it is bound up as not only aristotle
realized but but as his teacher plato
had realized with
conceptions of justice and injustice
right and wrong in ways that other
emotions tend not to be
and
it's able to motivate us
even to resist the other passions
in ways that the other emotions don't
don't seem to be able to do
what i've given you here
are
two of the you might think of them as
the slices looking in at the phenomenon
of anger
aristotle looks at anger in terms of a
num number of different dimensions the
two that he spends the most time on are
what in that that first handout i'm
calling the emotional psychological
dimension
and the ethical proretic dimension
and moral choice
so
what we're actually looking at there is
what is anger is an emotion
how does it function
and then
what it what ought to be in aristotle's
view our
on anger as morally good or bad
so
if you look at the first part which has
to do with
virtue's advice is concerned with anger
all of you are familiar i'm sure with
this notion that you know for aristotle
virtue is the the mean in between two
extremes
uh with with respect to anger it's going
to be feeling anger at the right time
for the right reasons towards the right
people to the right extent
all those sorts of qualifiers in the
middle there will be some cases where
it's going to be not being angry
there will be other cases where it
actually means being forgiving towards
people
it'll mean there there'll be certain
limits on the anger that a person feels
it'll be to some degree controlled even
though it's one of the most uncontrolled
of our emotions
and then we have then we have two
extremes right
and the extreme that he thinks doesn't
happen too often although this is you
know something we can look into more is
people not getting angry enough
or not getting angry when they ought to
get angry
aristotle doesn't think that that's
really a big issue and again we you know
this is something we could explore in
greater life what he's much more
concerned with are ways in which we go
wrong after we do get angry
or
in the ways that we get angry
so he gives you a number of different
vicious dispositions of access and i'll
just run through these very quickly so
there's the quick tempered people for
example
quick tempered people get angry
much more quickly than they ought to so
it doesn't take much to set them off
right
um causal is the orgy
they get angry at the wrong people over
the wrong things
the good thing about them is that as
quickly as they get angry they tend to
lose their anger
so they're not as bad as some of the
other people that he talks about in here
like the rageful who get angry quickly
and over everything this is you've seen
some people like this everything sets
them off they are at the point where
they may actually be some something
in a state similar to what aristotle
calls brutality when vice goes to a
you know extreme
at a certain point it becomes almost
inhuman there are some people whose rage
goes that far
then there's the bitter temper they
remain angry for a long time they keep
their anger in they are resentful until
they actually get some sort of
satisfaction we call these grudge
holders
that's a vice in aristotle's view that's
a
failure on the person's part not just in
how they feel the emotion but in how
they're
you know thinking about the emotion how
reason is coming into play with the
emotion
they actually think that that's the
right thing for them to do that's part
of what makes them vicious
so that's one way to look at anger you
can look at it in terms of
virtues and vices
notice that there's a lot of different
qualifiers
when it comes to this
you should become angry
with the right people on the right
grounds for the right amount of time
up to a certain point
in a certain way that means the
expression or the action
these are all important things for
figuring out whether anger is justified
whether the way in which a person is
acting is appropriate
another way to look at anger is in terms
of the rhetoric analysis
in the rhetoric aristotle is not really
concerned with the rights and wrongs of
anger
he's concerned with other issues
he's concerned with what actually does
make people angry what is anger
it's interesting that in the ethics he
doesn't give you a definition of anger
he only gives you definitions of anger
in other words the most important one is
in the rhetoric he also gives you sort
of an offhand one in the topics
and also one in the uh
or actually two in the uh de anima
but the most important one is taking
place in the rhetoric and notice how
complicated it is
it's a desire accompanied by pain for
apparent retribution aroused by an
apparent sliding against oneself or
those connected to oneself the sliding
being undeserved
so all that is packed into anger have
you ever thought about that when you got
angry at somebody you know what am i
experiencing a desire accompanied by
pain for apparent retribution aroused by
an appearance sliding against oneself or
those connected with oneself
the sliding being undeserved you don't
think about that
but
on a certain level you actually do think
about that
aristotle would say this is what's going
on in your soul
when you're angry this is what's going
on in other people's souls when you make
them angry or when you observe them
getting angry notice there there's a
number of different components to this
there's what we could call affective
components
and then there is perceptive or
judgmental or if you like cognitive
components so there's two sides to anger
and they they fuse into each other
what are the affective components
there's desire auraxis this is the
broadest term that aristotle uses for
desire
which comprises
you know the appetites
what he calls rational desire wish
blasis
thumus and also the passions
um even pro-racist he says is a type of
desire at one point although that could
be that could be debatable
so you have desire what is the desire
for it's not just desire for anything
it's desire for retribution
what else pain the angry person feels
pain
aristotle says they feel pain over what
they they originally got angry about but
they also feel pain in being angry
then they also feel pleasure that's not
in this definition but very quickly
after that he also says well angry
people also feel pleasure what do they
feel pleasure in
imagining getting revenge
actually taking revenge some people
arguably
become
vicious with respect to anger because
they actually like being angry they
enjoy the vitality that it brings to
them
what else there's perceptive or
judgmental components so there's this
this word apparent in there that's
phenomena in
greek so it could be a parent it could
be public it could be you know a number
of different things the idea is that
it has to do with our sort of
interpersonal perspective that we we
experience with each other we're not
just isolated monads
we're existing inter-subjectively
and it also has to do with
the imagination
anger can be aroused very easily by
imagining that somebody else is doing
something even if they're not
you've all experienced that as well
sliding
we're going to talk about that in a
moment the sliding has to be perceived
as being undeserved so if a person sees
themselves being put down but they think
that the other person has a right to put
them down or that it's appropriate they
they don't get angry aristotle says it
also has to be not just against anybody
that would be a different kind of
emotion that aerosol calls nemesis or
indignation
but against oneself or those connected
with oneself although this can extend
very far in the imagination can't it
it's very easy to identify in ways that
probably aren't you know practically
reasoning it out aren't very smart to do
and get angry as a result when somebody
insults that person
and then it has to do with retribution
timorasis what is temerasus
um it's it's
not just simply getting revenge there's
a sense in which it means putting
something right
and so when one gets angry it's a moral
emotion
it can it can easily turn
against morality
but anger is always you might say
inhabited by moral sentiments and guided
by them could be misguided ones
could be ones that are on track
but it's always involved
now this lighting is something else that
we want to think about if we're thinking
about rationality and emotion because
these are the things that somebody is
perceiving or
or
assuming is taking place
sliding is in greek oligoreo
it means you know to make less of
something
and aristotle picks out three main types
of this maybe maybe this isn't the most
exhaustive way of looking at it maybe
there's other things he's left out but
these cover a lot of ground one is
contempt or cataphronesis literally
looking down upon somebody so any sort
of activity by which a person actually
does look down on somebody or treats
them as being of less importance than
they they feel that they deserve
or makes them feel to be
less to be disregarded
then there's spitefulness this goes
beyond contempt spitefulness is when you
actually mess with somebody and you do
something to impede them not because
you're getting anything out of it but
just to mess with them
and we've all seen people behave this
way
at different times and then there's
hubris
which you know oftentimes we translate
like you know this great fault aristotle
uses in a much wider sense insults are
hubris
picking on people is hubris
could be also you know this is wanton
outrage is how we often translate it but
we don't talk about that much in our
society
and with hubris the person who is acting
out of that is doing so to
get pleasure for themselves out of
forcing the other person into a kind of
shameful
or subordinate situation
so aristotle thinks that these are the
things that actually these are what push
our buttons this is what makes us get
angry these are the causes
of anger
and then
i'm not going to go all over all of
these but they're worth you know taking
a look at
he lays out some characteristic dynamics
of anger
in the rhetoric he's very interested in
doing a
pretty careful analysis of what it is
that makes people angry
and what makes them more angry what
makes them less angry
notice just a few of these
people get angry at a person not for
what they in fact do or have done
necessarily but what one assumes they
are likely or will do
likely to do or will do
so we we get angry at people not just
for the past or the actual present but
for an imaginary future in which they
haven't even done the thing that we're
angry at them for
that does occur doesn't it
people get angry when another person
prevents hinders or even fails to help
them with something that they want if a
person has a state of unsatisfied desire
and you get in their way you will
probably make them angry
and you can think of things as a
commonplace as being out there in
traffic
right why do we get so angry when we're
stuck in traffic
you know we don't know most of those
people that we're involved with
we're mad because it's taking us 20
minutes to get someplace that should
have taken us five minutes or because
the lights are poorly coordinated
you know and we're stuck waiting there
or somebody wants to make a left turn
why are they making a left turn at this
time of the day
you know these are the sorts of things
that that we do get angry about
aristotle's you know of course you don't
have cars or anything like that but this
is very familiar stuff
one of the ones that i really like is
people become angry when what they value
or literally are serious about is
denigrated or treated contemptuously by
others and aristotle follows this up by
saying and if they're insecure about it
if they feel that
they
lack the thing that's being devalued or
they don't have it to a considerable
degree
if they're not entirely secure in their
possession of it then they get even
angrier
so you know what would be some great
examples of this think about how angry
people get in having moral discussions
with each other
when they're not particularly good
people
and if you point that out to them
that tends to provoke anger doesn't it
why is that you know aristotle's noting
that that's the case we want to know if
we're doing a fully you know sort of
aristotelian scientific investigation we
want to know why that is the case i'm
not going to spend a lot more time on
that at this point
because we want to now talk about across
here so
what is across you
and
you know when we ask that question we
also want to know what's its opposite or
what aerosol calls encroachia having
self-control literally self-mastery
um well i give you in this handout a
number of different places where he
talks about it and a bunch of different
recurring themes that you see popping up
over and over again
aristotle does talk about it at great
length in nickel mccain ethics book
seven but there's a lot of other places
where he he addresses it as well and he
doesn't always use the same language but
i think there is a sort of consistency
to this
before we go into that there is a
distinction that aristotle didn't make
clear
that i think would be useful for us to
make and that would be between two
different
ways of looking at accracia
sometimes across here is
a matter of a person's personality we
say that a person is a craddock and not
just in this situation but but in
general
so when he's talking about it nicole
mccain ethics
book seven some of the time he's saying
well look there are certain people who
are you know virtuous or people who are
vicious and then there's these people in
between some of them are more
self-controlled some of them are less
self-controlled and you can in a certain
way rely on
a person who's less self-controlled to
not get it right and to to
to give in to their desires much more
often is that actually part of their
character it's kind of hard to say using
aristotle's concepts because he actually
says they go against their cro-racists
their their their choice
but he also you know at least in in the
poetics talks about people being inconse
being consistently inconsistent you
should represent them if they're
inconsistent as being consistently
inconsistent and that kind of suggests
that
maybe there is a kind of character type
of theocratic
or maybe there's character types
theocratic with respect to this with
respect to this
then there's cases
where a person who
is usually self-controlled gives in
or maybe even a person who's virtuous
virtuous people fall
they give in
they're not a craddock all the time
they're creating this occasion in this
case in this situation so it's good to
sometimes distinguish between the two of
those as you're reading through that
um some of the main themes
uh having to do with with the acrosia
like i put here internal conflict
between a passionate emotional or
desirous part and a rational principle
part of the person that seems to be
integral to the phenomena or phenomena
you know the the whether we have more
than one type of accracio
there's a distinction between a state of
moral viciousness vice that aristotle
makes and the state of akrasia and the
difference there has to do with the
rational part of the person
is the rational part functioning
or has it become corrupted
has it gotten things you know typically
habitually wrong
there's a distinction between across the
a
state a la state where you lose
self-control and then encroaching a
state where you actually have
self-control where you make yourself do
what you know is right even though you
don't really feel like doing it
you don't particularly desire it
he has a semi-socratic treatment of
across you in terms of knowledge and
some sort of failure to use the
knowledge one possesses and we'll look
at that in a moment
and then he distinguishes between across
here in relation to desire for
food drink sex
and other types of lacrossia
he distinguishes between two modes of
across here rashness
and then
weakness of some sort and then he also
does another distinction between
across here concerned with with
pleasures and
softness concerned with not resisting
pains
and you know is there a fundamental
distinction between those well you could
think of a cross you have per se as as
you know being here and then you you
distinguish another type of across you
and and softness here
and
that might be the most helpful way to
think of it now if you look at this
section about conflict in the aeocratic
person you notice he doesn't always say
the same thing
but what he's saying is more or less
consistent
you know what's on one side
tends to be things like epithelia which
is his word for we translate it as
appetite or
sometimes it gets translated as desire
by itself which is a little misleading
because there's other types of desire
desires for physical pleasures
or to get rid of
certain pains
what else he talks about arrexis but
that's you know the most broad term for
for desire affectivity he also talks
about pathos which is you know the
emotions generally but can comprise a
few other things
he also brings up fontasia imagination
sometimes across is a matter at least in
nick of mccain ethics 7-7
it's a conflict between imagination and
logos what's on the other side
well the
the faculty of reason or sometimes
intellect dianoya
all these these other things pro-racist
moral choice
there so you've got you know if you if
you put them all together in kind of a
composite picture you've got desire
broadly speaking over here
not every kind of desire because
bulalosis which is which is uh i don't
know that's that's that's council sorry
um
belaces uh rational desire is over here
as well but that's rational desire
so you have a conflict between
desire in some sense emotions in some
sense and then
a better part of ourselves a higher part
which should lead us into
thinking things through right
practically rat uh
practically reasoning on what the good
thing is to do
that seems to be okay for when we're
thinking about some kinds of across you
it gets a little murky when it gets to
anger and we'll look at why in a moment
another thing i've got this just chart
here for you about comparing moral
states what's the fundamental difference
there
in the vicious person
the
rational part of the soul has become
corrupted
the person
not only desires the wrong things they
think those are the right things so the
greedy person
doesn't see being greedy as a bad thing
as a matter of fact they think everybody
else are a bunch of suckers for not
being greedy like them
the coward tends to see other people as
being at the other extremes being far
too rash
and so they see courage itself
in a wrong way they mistake that they
mistake their own
uh behavior and their own emotions they
think that they're actually in the
middle they're in the right place that's
part of what makes them vicious
that's not the case for the aeocratic
theocratic knows that what they're doing
on some level
is the wrong thing
but they're giving into something so
what we want to know is then how does
this happen how are they able to
actually give into things
that way
and this poses a big problem in moral
philosophy if you know if practical
rationality actually does culminate in
you want to do this and it operates you
know in a very strict way it seems like
you couldn't possibly be a critic if you
know what the good thing is that would
necessitate you to actually do the good
thing
and if you aren't doing the good thing
it must be because you actually don't
don't know it that way
there's something you know a failure of
reasoning going on not a failure
necessarily a desire
aristotle distinguishes two modes
of across him
he talks about rashness
and weakness and this offers one way of
maybe making some sense of this the rash
person he says doesn't actually
deliberate and
doesn't engage in deliberation or
reasoning in response to the situation
or the desires that that provokes in
them
and what happens is they they
go off too quickly they go off as we
often say half cocked right
what do we mean by that a gun is half
cocked it'll go off a lot easier if it
is than if it's
at rest position
so their letter they're driven by their
passion that gets them going and they
just find themselves now oh i did the
wrong thing and afterwards they feel bad
right
but at the time it seems like they
couldn't have prevented themselves
because they didn't they didn't actually
think about it they didn't use reason
when they had the opportunity to do that
and aristotle suggested maybe if they
stopped you know took a deep breath
backed up
started to think about these things they
wouldn't be that way
but what makes them rash people they
don't tend to do that right then there
are people who are
who have a weakness he says they do
actually engage in deliberation or
reasoning
and through passion he says they don't
remain within what they've decided or
resolved
so they they actually may come to a
resolution i'm not going to go have
seconds or thirds you know because i
shouldn't do that i'm trying to
stay on a diet and then they find
themselves
in this case i think i can make an
exception
and they go do it
they've resolved not to do it they know
that it's bad for them to do it
but they go and do it anyway
you know or you know think about one
that aristotle doesn't discuss
staying up too late watching shows
you know common thing that happens uh in
college and for many other people i'm
just going to watch one more show
because it's entertaining and i'd kind
of like to see what's going on if you
have netflix that's a particularly
across yet producing
thing because it's got all these things
in series and if you've watched one of
the shows well you know that the other
one is going to be pleasurable too and
you want to know what happens especially
if it's you know a connected series my
wife and i have been watching the
walking dead you know because we didn't
get to see it at first and
you know you say i'm only gonna watch
one show and then we're gonna get back
to work or we're gonna go to sleep or
something like that and then you say
well
it's only another 45 minutes
and then you know pretty soon it's one
in the morning
now that was doing that was doing the
wrong thing in a kind of trivial way
it's not like we killed somebody right
because we lost control of our anger but
it's a case of of what we could call
lacrossia you know what the right thing
to do is but you're just not doing it
that would be a case of weakness
aristotle would say
now we come to another main facet of
aristotle's treatment on the cross
this issue of knowledge
aristotle
um
ends up taking this pretty socratic line
of
maybe the aeocratic person doesn't
really know what they're doing in some
sense
but then he goes beyond you know
platonic treatments of these sorts of
things and he says well if that's the
case then then
how does that happen
how can we have knowledge
and not actually be using the knowledge
how can it be unengaged you might say
and so he distinguishes four
types of this and some commentators take
these as being you know sort of
exhaustive categories that are distinct
from each other i don't actually think
it's the best classification that he
could have produced
i think some of them kind of blend into
each other
but this is what he this is what he gets
so there's four types of
lack of knowledge or not using the
knowledge that you have so in across the
type one he distinguishes between two
senses of knowing
he says you can actually
know something and be using that
knowledge
or exercising that knowledge and you can
also know something but not be using or
exercising that knowledge it's just sort
of in the back of your mind it's not
engaged it's not active
you know if you want to think about this
in less moral terms think about when you
go and take a test and you actually do
know what you're doing or you know the
procedure you know the answer but you're
not able to bring it to the surface
and sometimes that you know frustrates
you sometimes you don't even realize
that you didn't do that until you get
the test back and you see
how could i have gotten that one wrong
i knew that right
well that could be that sort of thing
and aristotle frames this in terms of
whether
one is is conscious of it the knowledge
or whether one is looking at the
knowledge he uses the word um that in
some sense we use for theory but also
means to look at things to
contemplate them
that's not particularly helpful for
understanding anger i think
and it's pretty general so let's look at
the more specific types so type two
here aristotle introduces uh the
practical syllogism
which
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
two premises in a conclusion that isn't
always you know what aristotle
necessarily means by syllogism in some
respects it is but but it seems like
there could be a lot broader arguments
but the general idea is that there's
some sort of reasoning process that you
could represent in argumentative terms
by which a person ultimately culminates
in i should do this or i shouldn't do
that
or you know actually doing the thing
right or perhaps in the case of anger
and feeling anger i feel anger because a
reasoning process that takes place
and when we have a practical syllogism
um
aristotle says we have two kinds of
premises we have universal premises and
we have particular premises that allow
us to specify what it is that we're
talking about
so
you know here's just one example that we
could use for anger
people wearing striped shirts this is
going to be a very bad argument by the
way people wearing striped shirts
are
expressing contempt towards people with
striped ties
that guy over there is wearing a striped
shirt
showing contempt towards me should make
me angry
therefore you know i should get angry or
the conclusion could just be i get angry
right
kind of silly
but you see that there's some universal
premises in there then there's a and
there's that guy doing that that's
that's a particular premise
aristotle says that it's possible for a
person to know the universal premise
and for that to be you know actively
working in their head but they get the
particular one wrong
they're not using it
and this would seem to apply for anger
more to like prohibitions
i should not
strike people
when i'm angry unless i have very good
cause
this person over here has made me angry
but they're a person who i should not
strike
either we could say something like i
should not strike my family when i get
angry right
this person over here is a family member
but you forget that
you forget that that particular premise
and then you go and you smack it
or you could think in terms of like
cause and effect you know if i behave in
such in such a way
people won't like me i you know here's a
person over here
who i'm angry with do i actually go and
you know abuse them
strike them
do something to hurt their interests to
show that you know they've done me wrong
and i have to get revenge on them you
know somewhere along the line something
gets forgotten
something particular gets forgotten
that that could make some sense in
addition there's there's another problem
too universal premises are composed of
terms
and maybe you get one term right but
don't get the other term right
you mix them up aristotle thinks that
it's possible for us to reason
incorrectly
and he talks about this in a number of
places
um so that's one candidate then there's
across your type 3 this seems to be the
best candidate because he actually talks
about anger there
and he says
a person can have knowledge and not use
it when in certain states what are some
examples of those states when they're
asleep or insane or drunk
right
you might say well how does sleep fit in
there well you know people dream and
walk around and do things i i know
people who can talk in their sleep and
actually carry on conversations that
seem to be quite rational you can
actually ask them are you sleeping right
now and they'll say no i'm not sleeping
he'll say repeat to me what i just said
to you they'll say you just asked me if
i was if i was sleeping turns out they
were sleeping the whole time so there's
something that can actually you know
take take some sort
of action or effect during that um what
are some of the other ones he says when
a person is in literally one of the
passions
what's one of the passions
anger
right that's some ways the most
passionate of the passions
and that in what seems like an
afterthought he says that the thumbos
and epithumia aphrodisiac which means
sexual desire
and certain other passions modify the
body sometimes causing insanity
and that's a whole other interesting
thing to explore the main point there is
he's singling out anger
he has something
which would fit into this and then he
has some some really interesting stuff
he says this is like people who
recite verses of empedocles and they
don't realize that they're doing it a
person can articulate the knowledge that
they have
without actually being able to use that
knowledge so imagine an angry person
who in the course of their anger can
actually say i should not hurt this
person
i shouldn't say this sort of thing
and yet they do it
why because that knowledge that they
have that would restrain them is not
actually being used
finally we have the fourth type of
lacrosse hair gets even more interesting
we can have more than one practical
syllogism at work at the same time why
because we're complex beings
there's always a lot more going on with
us than we represent in theory of action
where you know you've got this agent and
they've only got this one practical
syllogism going on in their head and it
leads them to this one result we're
complex contradictory beings and we
don't start out rational
aristotle says that children don't have
rationality they don't have logos yet it
develops in them they do certainly have
epithelia and themos they can get angry
and they can desire things and they have
you know all sorts of patterns
established within them
by the time that that they reach
adulthood and most of us adults are not
fully rational
you know we're rational a good part of
the time
and um
some of us more some of us less our
rationality often reaches certain limits
so it's quite plausible that we could
have more than one practical syllogism
actually going on in our heads at the
same time
and he gives us this example one should
not taste things of this sort so imagine
imagine that there's something that is
sweet and yet poisonous
um i can't i don't have anything offhand
that fits the bill that comes to mind of
course what's that parsley
art is it yeah
i thought i actually had a bitter kind
of taste okay so arsenic is sweet and
poisonous so there's a nice big jar nick
out there
you know you shouldn't eat the arsenic
because it's going to kill you right
or antifreeze for dogs you know why do
dogs lap up antifreeze it's a salty
sweet taste that they can't get enough
of
humans don't do that thank god but
so what does that tell you i should
avoid this thing right that's that's the
culmination of that
but
at the same time within the person
there's this other practical syllogism
that's going on all sweet things are
pleasant he says that thing over there
is pleasant because it's sweet therefore
i should taste it and this kind of shows
you that there have to be a lot of other
premises packed into this in order to
make this work as a process of explicit
reasoning but you get the idea
there's a there's a reasoning process
that culminates in don't do this and
then there's another reasoning process
that somewhere along the line says yeah
go ahead and do this and where does
desire fall in desire like makes this
one more effective
more active it gives it greater weight
because it's what you wanted to do
anyway
so reason is telling you two different
things
right reason is telling you hey don't do
that
or actually in some cases go ahead and
do that that's the right thing to do
and then
another line of reasoning that's more in
line with the desire
is saying no no that's a good thing for
you to do you ought to do that
so
in this case
you know
is knowledge missing it doesn't seem to
be missing it's almost as if you have
too much knowledge
or
the knowledge is somehow distorted in
some way it's hard to see with some of
this how exactly aristotle wants us to
fit but could this fit anger
i think so
the angry person often has all sorts of
contradictory desires pushing them at
the same time think about what it's like
when you get angry you have thoughts
sort of rolling through your head
and some of them you may actually you
know have a sort of internal sensor that
says uh you're crossing a line here
don't say that to this person you're
going to really hurt their feelings
you're going to be sorry about this
later and then you find yourself doing
it anyway because another part of you
says
screw them
they deserve this i have a right to say
this sort of thing at this time
um
there's a lot of things like that or
think about you know when people
catch themselves and they're angry and
they have that opportunity to intervene
and say you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to like count to 10 and take
some deep breaths
and i'm i'm not going to continue this
conversation right here right now
because i'm already so angry about it i
need to get a hold of myself
that's you know sort of a line of
reasoning that's a culmination of one
and then at the same time there may be a
part of themself that's saying
that's stupid
that's for you know that that's a good
idea in a lot of cases but this person
really has ticked me off and i have a
right since i'm ticked off to this
degree not to have to do this namby
pamby stuff over here and they actually
put my foot down and defend my you know
whatever you want right two lines of
reasoning going on
and
which has desire
well the line that leads us to doing
what we want not to do
so um
there's there's another way of
understanding this issue of knowledge
and
it's not something that i put into the
handout because it's something that i'm
exploring and it's not something that i
came up with but there are some other
good aristotelian scholars who are
suggesting this miles burnout's a
a prime example
in a article con
called um
on learning to be good
he suggests that
the knowledge that theocratic
has is not knowledge
to the full extent that say the virtuous
person has or perhaps even the
incredible person has
that there's a sort of lack of
distinctness to it or a
you know hasn't been quite you know
i don't want to say burned into the
person's mind because that's a little
bit you know
the wrong metaphor but there's something
about it that's not fully
as distinct not grasping the kind of
situation that they're in and this is
something that's worth worth um thinking
out a bit more maybe the the connection
between knowledge and affectivity
in acrosia is a bit more complex than
what aristotle himself laid out
if we go forward with this then what
does aristotle explicitly say
in nico mccann ethics book seven he says
you have different types of accracia
different ways a person can be a critic
um there's across this you know sort of
simply or per se and that's with respect
to the the pleasures and pains of bodily
desires you know having sex
eating drinking i would say it probably
could extend to like sleeping you know
when you when you sleep in too much and
you hit the snooze button a lot of times
i'd be willing to say that that would
fit under a crosstail
simplicitor
aristotle didn't have that that sort of
thing available to him and he didn't
seem to be particularly worried about
sleeping or laziness as as an issue but
you know we can see that as flock right
maybe there are some people who are not
viciously slothful
but aerocratically slothful
and then we have across what he calls
catamara so in a qualified way with
respect to some sort of thing and i'm
not going to talk about those except
with one particular case with respect to
anger
and it has to do with
anger which is involving a desire and
where do we place it then if with
regular across here you've got you know
virtue over here vice over here
self-control or encroachia lack of
self-control across ya what are the
virtues in vice is concerned
well the virtues and advice is concerned
or what he calls temperance or
moderation on the one hand with respect
to bodily pleasures and the temperate
person
doesn't take too much they don't go back
for thirds and not because they they
really wanted to add thirds but because
they recognize that's the right thing to
do and they they want to do the right
thing they take pleasure in that
their desires are actually curbed to the
right extent then there's the encratic
person who says yeah i'd really like to
order pizza at you know
midnight
but i know i shouldn't eat pizza at
midnight
particularly before i go to sleep if i'm
not going to exercise
so i won't order pizza i will follow
reason and not my desires they're not
you know temperate yet
because they're resisting desires
but they're on their way
then there's the encrypted person
and then finally are the the credit
person and then finally of the vicious
person the immoderate person who says
yeah i mean i should have pizza all the
time
pizza you know is good for you
as a matter of fact those who don't have
it there's something wrong with them
that
what's what are the virtues and vices
done with anger
well it's those virtues and vices that
we looked at before so if you have the
if you have the acrylic and the
endocratic person here the
lack of self-control person and the
person who is self-controlled with
respect to the emotion of anger
then you have the virtuous person with
respect to anger what we call the gentle
or mild
or good tempered person
and then you have all these other
vices over here
and you know where would where would the
vices of deficiency fit in aristotle
doesn't seem to worry about that too
much but we could we could explore that
further but we definitely have vices of
excess when it comes to anger then we
have people who get way too angry too
quickly
okay well i'll wrap this this up then so
um a few other things that he does say
about this uh explicitly in in book
seven
um
he says that anger is better
to be a kratican than other things
that'd be a little bit puzzling i mean
it's pretty destructive isn't it
so why would aristotle think that anger
is better he says that it involves
reason to a greater extent so that
theocratic person with respect to anger
is following reason is actually
controlled by reason
but not
fully
and he gives this example of hasty
servants who listen to half of what's
being said when they rush off to do it
what does anger do anger perceives some
sort of insult
and he actually says in that reason or
imagination perceives an insult and then
rushes off to take revenge or take
timorasis
so that's one plausible reason why
it's better morally to be a critic with
respect to anger and then he gives
several other reasons which don't strike
me as on their face being particularly
good reasons but are worth exploring
uh later on one is he says that it's
it's excusable it's more excusable to
follow natural desire and thumbos anger
is more natural than epithelia the
desires of the flesh
he says then those which are not
necessary and which are excessive
but this doesn't seem to make that much
sense because that would work for like
super excessive
desires for for sex or food or things
like that but what about our ordinary
ones
that that doesn't seem to apply there so
that i'm not sure why he makes that
argument another which is a bit more
persuasive he says anger is more open
more above the board
whereas epithelia
desire tends to be a little bit more
secretive more crafty
that sounds good at first but then what
about people who hide their anger and
then they take revenge later
or passive-aggressive people
you know that doesn't seem to fit that
and then aren't there some people who
are just straight out in the open about
their physical desires and they're going
to pursue them and you know they they
they're willing to say yeah i know it's
the wrong thing to do but i'm going to
do it we have reality shows about that
right
and i think there were probably a lot of
people in aristotle's time
along those lines
um another reason that he has which fits
in well with some of the other
discussions of anger is the person who's
acting in anger is not committing hubris
they're not doing it just because
they're
sticking it to the other people and you
know putting them in a subordinate
position
well that's an interesting one aristotle
actually says that we don't get angry
with those who are angry at with us
because they're not they're not you know
doing it they're not angry with us and
behaving angrily because
they they want to
or because they're happy with that
they're actually feeling a kind of pain
well
yes and no
i mean once a person goes too far with
anger don't we often find ourselves
taking a kind of satisfaction that we
might not want to admit to necessarily
but but is there where now i've got you
and i'm gonna stick it to you
and make you feel
something and then it quits being just
about
you know making the other person feel
our pain and there can be a kind of
pleasure to it
that would be hubris though so then that
wouldn't seem to be
you know
morally better and as a matter of fact
that could provoke anger on the other
person's part against them i understand
you're being angry with me but you went
too far when you
did this
there's a lot more that could be said
about this but we do have to have some
some time for discussion so um
what would you like to
to know about talk about
say i got right say i got wrong
say aristotle should have thought more
about
yeah
is anger always associated
with relationships to other
or
oh
yeah
aristotle
as far as i can tell and i i maybe i've
missed you know a reference to it some
some
much less red text
i've never seen him say anything about
being angry with ourselves
he can talk about like a conflict within
ourselves but he doesn't talk about us
getting angry with ourselves and you
know
plato does in the republic
that that guy that's where you know he's
doing the analysis that shows us that
thumos is something different he says
that guy you know wanted to look at
corpses and then he gets angry at his
eyes and says go ahead and look you know
and and this becomes a really important
thing in christian treatments of anger
um you know like if you think about john
chaosium cassian says the only person we
should ever be angry at is ourselves
any other time it's always going to be
terrible you know it's going to lead us
astray aristotle doesn't seem to have
something like that
yeah actually i i thought of a text
there's nick monk in 98 where he's
talking about love of oneself and touch
the feet of oneself yeah especially if
people hate themselves but hate is
something different than men
well in the rhetoric hate is very
different than anger hate is
something that's longer lasting
that is uh
directed at a type of person for what
they are wills wills bad it wills harm
or badness to them anger can be
satisfied hatred
only with the extinction of the other
person
but you know something that would open
the door to that
in politics book five when he's talking
about the causes of stasis
um he he lays out that hatred is one of
the causes of stasis and anger there he
says can be a cause of hatred which is
something that they haven't seen a lot
of other moral theorists augustine is
very worried for example
about anger's tendency to turn into
hatred
you know
to congeal into it you might say so i
think that would offer a possibility
for that
yeah all right
i figured a couple things but so you
were talking about
you know weakness of will right is this
is this a rational problem then
um
aristotle's trying to resolve the issue
of whether or not we do harm knowingly
for ourselves right
so
it seems like some cases of anger
uh and then the last thing you were
talking about where he talks about that
actually anger listens to reason yes it
seems like some of them some of them
rather than a lapse of will they're just
i have better reasons for being angry
uh about something than than rather than
not being angry in a particular
situation i mean you even talked about
you know there's anger in the right
situation so there's anger
yeah uh not getting angry enough so well
if you're if you're a critic
you're doing something that is in some
sense
wrong
so the aerosol thinks there's plenty of
situations where we ought to get angry
it's the right thing to do right
and up to this point say or or at this
person who actually harm us not at this
person who's affiliated with them over
here
um
and you're right there there is a sort
of sense of well for the for the ocratic
person this is a better
more rational
way to be
you know over here where i
attack this person here than this way in
which i say let it go or restrain myself
or forgive them
um but whatever solvents say in that
case that's like the the type four
across you two different practical
syllogisms going on and one gets the
force of desire with it it's actually
the worst argument
but it looks like the better argument
because the person isn't aggressive
yeah
um and and there's a really interesting
discussion of that in bernat's article
about why that would appear to be the
better argument he says that if we look
at across he has a sort of developmental
stage
we've had our bad arguments motivating
us a lot longer they they're you know if
we think of this in aristotelian terms
um as sort of you know in terms of
hexays right they're they're there in
our mind and our reason the bad
reasoning processes have been there
doing their work longer they feel more
natural
than
this you know
maybe what we learned in anger
management right or from from reading
augustine or guess what you grew up in a
violent home right
so it seems like it seems like it's more
rational but really what reason is or
really what anger is doing
is it's it's taking
rationality it's kind of it's putting it
within uh blinders i might say one of
the first things they teach in anger
management is as soon as you become
angry you become stupid
but you don't become stupid in the sense
like you forget everything you know
you become stupid that you you only
focus in on the things that you do and
one of the things that makes anger so
dangerous is it tends to face the very
things that would stand in its way
you know or to suck them in and to make
them work with like reason
you know
so okay so then yeah also you made some
mentioning city we're going to talk
about it but there's that this idea of
the knowledge that we have that we don't
have real good knowledge or bureaucratic
so
yeah we're
we're missing something we don't quite
have the uh
you know we don't have a whole picture
or something so
we say that person
they lack knowledge so they be ignorant
of their circumstances so it's not going
against reason
right they just don't
have the knowledge so it's not going
against
knowing uh what i know about myself so i
won't hurt myself now yes it's i just
don't or what i know about human nature
could be you know like somebody coming
from a violent household this is how we
express love
you know um that'd be the sort of
fundamental mistake about human nature
in relation but so that person's i'm
wondering about responsibility
that we don't hold that person
responsible when they complain that they
didn't have full knowledge right because
what we do when we get angry at them
response you know um i don't know
aristotle does seem to hold the creative
responsible
right but in that case if they're
lacking full knowledge if that's the
reason why they're acting that way then
can we hold them responsible doesn't it
just become an issue
i don't think anyone i don't think
anyone possesses full knowledge except
for the super virtuous person when it
comes to and even that person i doubt
yeah
how are you just absolutely virtuous
right because tomorrow you may not be
yeah so i think knowledge
it sounds almost like knowledge is an on
off switch right but i think we should
understand it more as being like a
dimmer switch it gets
you know it takes its hold it's able to
be more effective but at some point we
assign responsibility to people for
things right so that that's what you
know especially in a court of law as we
were hearing earlier yeah um it becomes
very definite since judgment as to
as to whether or not i'm rightly so
right i mean you know you think about
you know
you know
kids being tried as adults or something
you know they're 14 15. where's that cut
out twice you know i was thinking about
that earlier today because i i realized
that this this might come up
when it comes to
determining these things like aristotle
says it's hard to draw lines
you know who we should be angry with how
much we should be angry when we should
be angry
all those sorts of things and i think
that the only answer to that that we
would really get from aristotle would be
that that would be a matter of oasis
that would be a matter of
or
practical wisdom or one commentator i
like called it moral insight
and
so there is there is no
you know exact set of lines where we
could we can draw and say okay here cure
responsibility which didn't exist before
it begins
um
and you know that if that's the case it
may be that we're always like at the
least worst
answer to it you know because most of us
are not from emotions i know i'm not
you know
i'm not a very good judge when it comes
to my own anger or other people's anger
or you know with respect i'm better when
it comes to justice
not when it comes to anger or temperance
any of those sorts of things it seems
like we would have to and i don't want
to take up time but i'm talking about
the responsibility for you know claiming
responsibility would hold people
responsible and say they have knowledge
of what they're doing yeah this idea
that somehow like i got angry and i
didn't really know everything that was
involved in it so am i responsible for
it or not
you know another possible way of looking
at this would be aristotle thinks that
the
craddock person
does feel a sense of
shame or wrongness or pain or regret
in what they do
you know
whereas the vicious person doesn't
and
but if we if we wait for everybody to
to come forward and express their sense
of you know
guilt or shame or whatever it is then
there'd be a lot of people we'd have to
let off the hook
and there's a lot of people who we say
well they should have known
better and then you know the problem
also comes up too you know about the
vicious person
if we adopt that sort of way of looking
at the aristotle thinks the vicious
person is responsible for their
viciousness
you know he he lets other people off the
hook if they're beastial or you know
brutal
where any and he actually uses the
example of people who've been abused
in that case
but um he also he also seems to like
push them outside of the moral community
altogether
you know
following up on that i i think that the
the issue of
weakness and kind of wrongdoing in
general but from the socratic discussion
to the eurostation one is a fascinating
one because i think it gets
right into the sense almost a paradox of
culpability yeah it's how
how do you is it's much bigger
than a crazy i mean it takes in
wickedness it takes in negligence yeah
if
reason
is really what is crucial here and if
it's about knowing what is good
and if the knowledge or the judgment the
rational judgment is supposed to be
motivational
as
socrates and aristotle seem to think
that it is they hold some form of basic
what we would today perhaps call
cognitive internalism you immediately
get into a problem of how it is that
someone who could judge what is right
not be motivated to do so not in a sense
attempt to do so they must be
trying to explain how it is but explain
the problem
that doesn't appeal to ignorance
they really didn't know
which is in some sense what the wicked
the wicked have the wrong
judgments about what is in fact right
and the weak there's some sort of
motivation that it's overtaking them but
then their reason really isn't
in control or they haven't used their
reason
to mold and shape their desires and
their passions right so
the problem becomes
well could we hold them responsible find
them culpable for their limitations of
reason ah that's a good question any
limitations of reason yeah i think
because if they knew better and if they
knew they should have
they knew they should have improved
their reason
on this theory they would have improved
their absolutely they would have taken
these measures so the very fact that
they fail
is indicative of the limitations of
their reason if we want to look at it
through aristotle's eyes aristotle would
hold them accountable he says uh in the
discussion of ignorance
you know he's discussing this sort of
dialectically but a certain man is you
know
ignorant because he doesn't pay
attention to things well he let himself
become the kind of person who doesn't
pay attention to things he doesn't
literally care about them
but the question is how did he let him
do that
you want to trace it back further yeah
aristotle doesn't trace it back further
at a certain point he says we're you
know we are
responsible for these things um
and when it comes to knowledge or lack
of knowledge he doesn't say as much
about that as he does
our moral status these vicious people
became vicious by acting
viciously they didn't start out that way
and virtuous people likewise who we
praise and say they are responsible for
it they become virtuous by acting that
way so for him there doesn't seem to be
a big big there's not an irresolvable
problem of responsibility there
but i i but i do think that you know i
think what the question is is right i
mean i'm not denying
the textual yeah aristotle assigns
responsibility the question is is he
justified in doing it based on his own
his own beliefs his own theory is he
justified in designing i think i think
on on the basis of his own theory yes
i think if we're going to bring in other
sort of frameworks that made me know you
know there's other things he doesn't
address i was thinking about another
case that that his framework can't on
its face address which is let's say i'm
in anger management because i realize
i'm a vicious person with respect to
anger and i've hurt people in the past
and i feel
you know i feel bad about it but on the
same time when i'm actually angry i just
i just go and i can't help myself from
doing it so i'm in a certain sense in
between the vicious person and the
incredible
arizona doesn't have those
continuing anyway which which he should
and he could have on good aristotelian
grounds
now i'm in a situation and i you know
got up in my head my anger management
principles and i know i should
take a deep breath
walk away all these sorts of things i
know even cognitive things like as soon
as i become angry i become stupid
so i better
as soon as i become angry i better find
some resources to seek out
that's you know
that's all on the point of reason i'd
say right
i don't do it
um
i become a critic in that respect
am i a critic or am i vicious
well in one aristotelian sense i'm
vicious
but in that in that case i shouldn't
even be able to you know
say well there's something wrong with me
right
but if i'm able to say there's something
wrong with me then i should be closer to
this this you know middle point and not
have these habits that are gonna sort of
irrevocably drag me in
well our ordinary moral experience tends
to be some there tends to
be moral development is this this
continual building process
and a lot of it is becoming aware of our
own
screw-ups how we're how we're
not thinking things out correctly and
then choosing to to think in terms of
different models
that probably doesn't address the
problem with responsibilities you're
posing